il ne pourra pas participer comme prévu
au marathon de boston reporté en
septembre pour cause d'épidémie du coc
vide 19 limité à une heure par jour
pendant le confinement pour aller courir
sidy diallo a décidé de reproduire chez
lui les 42 kilomètres de cette course
emblématique pieds nus l'idée de courir
aujourd'hui devant nous sommes en
confinement
moi j'essaie de motivation pour courir
partout
le confinement ne l'affectent pas je
respecte les règles et je sais pas tu
m'as vu je coule si la chaussée il n'y a
pas de voiture et à personne et je suis
très très loin des gens quand je cours
c'est la chaussée mais je déserte et je
suis loin de maison et quand je
rencontre des personnes qui sont sur le
trottoir je vais l'autre côté des sa
cuisine jusqu'à dans sa chambre ce
marathonien cours dont chaque recoin de
son appartement sur un carnet note
chaque aller-retour pour comptabiliser
le nombre de kilomètres effectués 100
200 300 400 concerts pour que j'arrive à
8,4 à chaque fois que j'avais plus de 5
km je note une heure à laquelle je suis
arrivé comme comme daddy cool chez lui
sidy diallo s'est préparé un parcours de
25 m en ajoutant les 15 marches de son
escalier pour ce marathonien de 65 ans
impossible pour lui d'arrêter de courir
malgré le confinement
ça fait 12660 marche que je dois monter
et descendre aujourd'hui donc là je suis
à 25 km donc j'ai encore du chemin et
mais c'est un problème
alors voilà les escaliers et on verra
tout le monde a des escaliers soit pour
les la cave soit plus à l'est aussi
au grenier ou là les immeubles aussi à
la cage d'escalier et ici je crois tout
le monde prend l'ascenseur donc en fait
la cage d'escalier aussi est libre on
peut faire de l'exercice tout en
respectant les règles gestes-barrières
le confinement de puits notre tournage
sidy diallo a fini son marathon à
domicile en challenge qu'il a relevé
pour transmettre un message positif et
énergique pendant cette période de
pandémie